todavian clowney a guy who has the
potential to be one of the most dominant
and disruptive players in the national
football league available still in free
agency and one of the big reasons he had
that sports hernia last year core muscle
surgery had the procedure after the
season and because of the covet 19
procedures teams can't bring him in for
a physical teams can't bring him in for
a visit teams can't sit down and talk to
him get a feel for where he is at this
stage of his career and chris that's one
of the big reasons why he's unsigned
definitely i mean he's scary that way
not only this injury but has injury
history and and as we've talked about
many times mike i mean he had micro
fracture surgery which is one of the
most dangerous surgeries anybody in
sports can get which means his knee is
basically bone on bone so there's always
going to be that concern about how much
longer that'll last clowney
is clearly the best defensive player
available and was even before the start
of free agency but it's just a question
of how many years does he have left how
much money do you invest in a guy like
that how much money is he asking for and
you're right mike i don't think any of
this is going to get cleared up until a
team can really get their hands on them
and and prod them and really figure out
where that body's at
which gives the seahawks essentially an
advantage for now but the thing is that
they don't have competition for his
services there's no reason to up the
offer so he'll get signed at some point
and it may not be until after these
protocols change and clowney can go
visit with a team
and uh have that team get to the right
level of comfort that physically he's
good to go others who are available
everson griffin and this one was kind of
strange
he
uh triggered an option to get out of his
contract in minnesota and then out of
the blue on friday his agent announced
that they're breaking off talks and he's
going to become a free agent well
it's four days into free agency i'd like
to think they would have exhausted all
that before free agency opened because
now uh you know a lot of the money's
been spent neverson griffin i think he's
gonna have a hard time finding a landing
spot chris
yeah well yeah you're right i mean he'll
he'll find a landing spot but he'll be
part of this next wave of guys that gets
signed and again with a guy like him
it's going to be about you know what
type of money is he asking for on the
open market and i think once he gets a
better feel for that and teams get a
better feel for that he will be signed
you know yes his best years are done as
you you and i both know but he's still a
good player he's good against the run
he's still one of the better pass
rushers in football not gonna sit here
and say he's top five or top ten in
football rushing the passer anymore but
certainly can add value to any team's
front four and i would think that
somebody snags them here in the next
five to ten days
jets receiver robbie anderson another
guy we were talking about during the
break who is
being hurt by these procedures that
prevent teams from getting a chance to
bring him in and talking to him right
definitely i mean that's that's the one
thing you know i i heard from from one
coach in the nfl like hey robbie
anderson we like his tape we like
everything about him but we're just
we're not going to sign them until we
get to meet the guy a little bit and and
anybody that follows the nfl knows
robbie anderson's had a little few
issues off the field hasn't been perfect
that way and i think team this is the
more example not necessarily the
evaluation the medical evaluation but
just getting to know the guy and all
right are we going to be comfortable
with him being in our building day after
day is he going to be a good teammate
and a good player that way all those
type of things that what needs to be
figured out with robbie anderson and
that's one of the other realities teams
are going to be wrestling with over the
next 31 days that's when the draft
happens some way somehow and the teams
don't have the luxury of bringing these
guys in
going to go see them all of that has
been scrapped leading up to the draft so
you're going to have some guys chris
some talented players are going to
tumble down the draft because teams
didn't get a chance to do their due
diligence
yeah you're right i think here this week
though we'll see the guys who are that
second level free agents that have no
big medical concerns i think we'll
continue to see them signed here slowly
but surely as the week goes on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports